[Musique]
on se voit on se connaît
quand le regards se croisent aux hâtives
on se promet
des plus belles phrases
te dirais
que moi la préface objet la cogne la
nation au sens
[Musique]
oui à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on a là
ken d'ici et d'ailleurs nous ferons face
grâce à nos esprits
si on s'embrasse la nation guéri
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bijoux
[Musique]
est-ce que tu le sens le bonheur qui se
dessine alors les gens
[Musique]
est-ce que tu le sens la chaîne
la nation de pizzas maison week-end fin
de semaine oui parce que tu dis là où
l'iphone le smartphone tient tous du
smurf prends mais tu dis n'importe quoi
là c'est désormais au nord à l'est nord
est en anglais bacon
[Musique]
williams
[Applaudissements]
je suis
où
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui
[Musique]
quelle forme
[Applaudissements]
g
prenez un petit peu et qu'on va se
retrouver dans un instant les choses
allaient bouger ray on passera par cette
porte
regardez ban et on passera main pendant
sept jours pour appâter par la grande
porte et chérie et dans un instant vous
découvrirez le nouveau plateau de tp
le public est là les chroniqueurs
soûlard vous nous avez manqué mes beauty
on est bien sûr en direct savard est
l'auteur
redémarrer dans là ce soir avec une star
internationale qui démarre atp
saraka politique on trouve le 7 décembre
au café de la danse aux capellans les
gibervillais je voulais absolument fou
louvre avec toi cette émission parce que
voilà le message est hyper important
fonds sera grand plaisir pleine forme et
sa démission et tu vas nous l'avons tous
ces lanceurs pour l'instant d comme
défaut de vous retrouver à plus de suite
le kit beauté